Our lives are made up of small moments
and small decisions.
Left or right,
walk or drive,
eat in or take out,
lend a helping hand,
or some words of encouragement
or an offer of support to a neighbor,
a colleague, a stranger.
Some of these decisions
are not like the others.
And with the world in this much pain,
it might seem futile to be focusing
on those kinds of micro decisions.
But the truth is
that we underestimate the power
of our own generous actions.
Every time we intentionally
choose generosity,
the effects of that choice
are more powerful
and more far-reaching than we might think.
The truth is that what one person
can accomplish is enormous.
I've been one of the many leaders,
many of them here in this room,
of Giving Tuesday since
it was created in 2012.
And it began as an experiment.
Could we use social media
to create a day of giving,
following two days of consumption,
Black Friday and Cyber Monday,
here in the US?
And if we could, would anybody
be interested in it?
Well, needless to say, the answer was yes.
But I think that even all of us
who were there at the very beginning
were genuinely stunned
by just how deeply and widely
the idea resonated.
Nonprofits and families and schools
and houses of worship
all joined in with such
enthusiasm and creativity.
People felt like they
were asked to be givers
or invited to be givers
for the first time,
or in a totally new way.
I will always remember
the woman who posted,
"I'm not rich,
I don't have a million dollars,
but I can help change lives
on Giving Tuesday."
And with the spark that that ignited,
it spread throughout
the whole United States
and then throughout the entire world.
And now, 11 years later,
Giving Tuesday is a year-round
global generosity movement
made up of thousands of leaders
and millions and millions of people
who are working to transform
their communities and their world,
one small act at a time.
And as a global family,
because that's how
we think about ourselves,
we look and sound and work and worship
in very different ways.
But what we share
and what keeps us together
and keeps us working, is a dream
of a future based in the value
of radical generosity.
That phrase might sound
like it means something big
or extreme or dramatic or newsworthy.
Or kind of scary.
But it's actually the opposite.
The word radical simply
means “from the root.”
And so we imagine a world
where generosity is simply
at the root of our decisions
and our behaviors,
even, and maybe especially,
down to our smallest
and most mundane ones.
I have essentially been on
a decade-long global generosity tour,
witnessing this principle
of radical generosity in action.
I have been welcomed and hugged and fed
in more countries than I can count.
And from Kenya to Colombia to Canada,
so many more places,
I have witnessed the hundreds
of ways that generosity manifests.
And what I have learned,
my understanding of what generosity is
and my appreciation
for what it can accomplish,
has expanded 1,000 times over.
I've unlearned a lot of lessons,
and I've learned a lot of lessons
about generosity.
Often when we think about giving,
we think about money.
And yes, money is an incredibly
important form of giving.
It is crucial for the health
and sustainability of our civil societies.
But thinking about giving
only in terms of money
is like thinking about love
only in terms of diamonds.
We love what we can measure,
we love what we can quantify.
But I think what we would love even more
is to live in a world
of immeasurable abundance,
empathy and solidarity.
Generosity builds a bridge
between this world that we live in now
and that one.
And it builds bridges between us
at the same time.
One small act at a time.
So what do some
of those small acts look like?
They might look like in Toronto,
where people chalked messages
of gratitude and love
on city sidewalks,
just to uplift the spirits
of anyone who might walk by.
And then a lot of the people
who did walk by picked up the chalk,
and they added their own messages.
This picture happens to be Toronto,
but this project actually happened
in dozens of cities across the country
and across the world.
Or in Nairobi,
where people painted rocks
with bright colors
and inspirational messages,
and they put them all over the city,
park benches, bus stops,
just to bring smiles
to the faces of strangers,
smiles that they would never even see.
And turning the Earth’s literal
most mundane object into a love letter.
In Jackson, Tennessee, one of our longtime
Giving Tuesday leaders, Allison,
was inspired to combat food insecurity
in her community in one small way,
which was building a set
of little free pantries.
And she put a message
on Facebook asking for help.
People responded and they built
an initial six boxes,
which local residents then stocked
with food and other supplies.
All of this done on donated supplies
and volunteer time.
And that has now turned into over 40 boxes
over three different counties,
with a network of hundreds
of volunteers keeping it stocked.
What these stories have in common,
some of them are much more elaborate
and some of them are literally
just a fleeting moment,
but what they have in common
is that each one inspired at least
one person who was watching.
Researchers think that
for every act of kindness
or good deed a person does
they can affect someone, or many people,
three or more degrees removed from them.
Imagine that next time you do
a small good thing for someone,
that you might be inspiring people
you will never meet
to do good as well.
Your one fleeting moment
could be amplified 100 times over.
But researchers also have found
that we tend to drastically underestimate
the effect of our own actions
and how much they will be
appreciated by the recipient,
and that that miscalculation
might hold us back
from doing nice things
for others more often.
We also think, often, that it's great,
like, let's do more nice things
for more people, yes.
But also, "my life is stressful
and hectic and hard,
and that takes up time
that I might not necessarily have."
I find myself in that thought
process all the time,
and what I remind myself of
is that generosity alleviates stress.
It doesn't add to it.
People who give are healthier
and happier and more hopeful.
Just the act of paying for coffee
for the person behind us
in line in the morning
measurably enhances our feeling
of well-being for the entire day.
This is Sujan.
He is a Nepalese restaurateur in London.
And Sujan has done
a world of good in his life.
But during the pandemic,
he started doing what he does best,
and he began to cook hot, free meals
for overwhelmed hospital workers.
And when he was starting to do that,
other people saw, they were inspired,
they asked if they
could join and help out.
And soon they were feeding
ambulance crews,
fire crews, charity workers.
And one year after Sujan started cooking
these delicious hot, free meals,
he delivered his 100,000th free meal.
Now, Sujan closes
his restaurant every Tuesday,
every Giving Tuesday,
so that he and his army of volunteers
can support their community
in whatever way is needed all day long.
And finally, this is Chloe.
And Chloe is 16 now,
but when she was just eight years old,
she would walk to school with her mom
and they would pass the same woman
without a home every day.
And Chloe
asked her mom a lot of questions.
Starting with "Why doesn't
that woman have a home?"
But also things like
"What about when she needs
to use the bathroom?"
"What happens when she has her period?"
Chloe was learning to sew at the time,
so she asked her grandma to help her
sew a beautiful tote bag,
and they filled it with toiletries
and hygienic products and other goodies.
And they gifted it to that woman.
Not just handed it to her,
but with connection and with conversation.
And the woman said she couldn't
even remember the last time
somebody had asked her her name.
Chloe has since made and delivered
5,000 of those bags.
Chloe also DM’d us on Instagram
to ask if we had a Giving Tuesday Kids
and if we didn't, could she start it?
(Laughter)
And of course -- because she's
a very entrepreneurial kid --
And of course the answer was yes.
And what can we do to help?
And a few years later,
there is a global community
of young people
who have performed hundreds
of thousands of acts of service,
fighting bullying and hunger,
and drawing attention
to mental health among young people
and the importance of community.
And they're connected to
and support each other.
So for every Chloe and Allison and Sujan
and the people with the chalk
and the people with the rocks,
there are countless millions more,
and the algorithms just don't put them
at the top of our feeds.
But they're there.
And if we pay attention,
then they remind us
that ordinary acts of giving
are actually extraordinary.
They remind us that generosity
is not a burden.
It's a gift.
And it's an antidote.
It's an antidote to our fear
and our anxiety,
to loneliness and isolation,
to outrage and indignation.
And they remind us that we have this tool
accessible to every single one
of us every day,
which is the power to change
someone else's day,
or maybe even life for the better.
And when we use that tool collectively,
we can build a more joyful,
more equitable and more peaceful future.
And that does not seem
like too radical a thing to imagine.
Thank you.
(Applause)